foreign
[Music]
Lord's podcast
hey everyone how are you this is Lord PD
here to give you another first look at
another game well I wouldn't say this is
a first look I would say this is an
expanded expect first look if you will
um this is for the game dice Legacy uh
they brought out an expansion where they
added a new type of dice class called
cultists uh and I really wanted to talk
to you about them now
um in this video I'm going to kind of
show you like a brief overview of me you
know playing the game and it looks very
similar to the original
um the original version of it but from
now you have uh the cultist dice which
uh you know they add more Dynamic uh to
the game they give you they don't they
have more abilities to to gather things
um they give you you know the ability to
to attack things a little more so it
gives you another dice roll uh situation
uh into the game uh they also can cause
problems for
um
the
for the other team for the enemies uh
when you're ending up finding them
towards the end so they they really are
a really really cool dice
um you can also sacrifice them uh to
allow you to get uh you know uh to get
more materials and things like that so
there's lots and lots of different
things you can end up doing with them
um so you know I just want you to say uh
this once again I love this I can see
the original
um this expansion with the with the
cultist dice it's just an added bonus to
it um and they gave you uh more
um versions of you know gameplay they
give you like the certain people that
you pick when you start with give you
positive and negative effects there's
lots of different things there and it's
really really cool uh if you're looking
to uh you know check them check out uh
dice Legacy uh go check it out and like
I said the expansion is pretty cool and
worth it uh the road map is in place
they're gonna have lots of updates so
get in now while you still can uh and
enjoy the game so once again this is
Lord PD uh you can check me out on
Twitch every Monday through Friday from
3 to 11 and also uh make sure you check
out uh Lords of gaming.net for all your
gaming news and the Iron Horse podcast
on Sundays on YouTube uh so go ahead and
check those guys out all right thank you
again and have a fantastic day bye
everybody
foreign
from start
um
foreign
food crates wreckage
Cook House
this will give us people back
trying to remember because it's been a
while
oh my God
foreign
District Hall
Wheat Farm
we're gonna need taverns
foreign
School ASAP too
uh
let's there we go
okay
iron
food
thank you
foreign
you know
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
as possible
foreign
like having the cultist eye so early in
the game
really messes you up
underground hunting ground ancient
maroons
encampments
foreign
foreign
interesting
so
oh it doesn't fully fill them up anymore
[Music]
oh oh wait a minute isn't that a a
knowledge thing
the technology research thing
foreign
makes sense coming back it's coming back
to me
a little bit
we need
that
because Gold Dot
um
we're gonna need more wood
I don't wanna
burn what we have
we're gonna need food
um
exploration
[Music]
we need to get some citizen die in here
oh the citizen dies will be a lot of
easier
an interesting Discovery we encountered
a small encampment the population looks
to be a aggressive and uncivilized
unfortunately our explorer was seen
while trying to sneak into their camp
and copyright guard this is sure to make
them even more bitter about our presence
unfortunate
wounded
survive the winter
oh
[Music]
I put one
here
um
foreign
we need to figure out what we're going
to do here
to keep this Supply up
I mean
ideally I'd put it there
but we would have to zero that out
um
to there
foreign
[Music]
to go
okay
we're gonna keep pushing that one
specific one
Stone
food
builds
is there like a hunting
okay
okay
useless
another useless role
active
okay let's hear
at the start of every season ever obtain
one knowledge
per different location type
inside citizen districts
when a building or location is destroyed
by fire increase the happiness of all
dice classes
Prosperity House can be used by any die
upgrade
oh so I could put any dye in there
to produce another dye
that's pretty good
um okay let's hear
here this is like the worst [ __ ]
rules ever pardon my language
too late in the year can't use that
that'll be done in two
I'm locking that so I don't lose it
we're gonna have to use that
I'm gonna lock that eat that
I was hoping to have a Cookhouse in the
steam
engine area all generator also
is going to be very very difficult to
survive the winner
there we go
ideally
I would want to put down
an herbalist here
and use the herbalist to continue to get
herbs from here
and then you put a dairy farm
over here and then you just use the
herbs that the guy would be getting from
here because it doesn't take anything
from the wood
demolish
um
curious to see if that'll work or not
and then the Cook House
which restores the durability to the
dice we could stick that in this area
so that we can continue to do things
throughout the whole entire winter
season
but like right now
I'm really worried about doing anything
with my dice
gonna lock this like this just in case
um
this will be good because we can use the
wheat
um
we got three two food
see you got Frozen
it's like he's like hey I got your stuff
back but I froze
all right let's hope
foreign
build
foreign
see if you freeze or not
it froze
or lasting of food in we have 19 wood
which is a positive
let's see what I mean it's gonna look
around
in those locations for herbs
where's pass
um
okay
answer chamber can also provide a random
trait
wheat Fields inside peasant districts
work also in winter
and then this is the citizen District
again
um
this is good
we would have to make sure that we have
the abilities to use it though
but one knowledge is pretty nice
too good
but you there
you there
foreign
we need to make a house
we need to make a house and a dairy farm
put you there
was you two there
I'm gonna reroll you
uh give me stone
all right we can work on that there
it's doing its thing
uh once that's done we'll pull out a
house
and we can put a house over here
I didn't think about it at the time
I wonder
if it'd be a good idea to put it here
um
uh yes I'm sorry guys I gotta check my
Lipscomb I'll be right back everybody
what's going on
it's just not
sorry kid I was sleeping like
gotta play for
play
friends
give me more
don't pretty much that's all I have
right now
everybody likes it you know what can I
say
I have a soothing voice
gotta be careful you know
it's really uh
this game is really interesting you
pretty much are playing on a Circle here
um it's not turn based you pretty much
pretty much so you're getting crispy
speeds so it makes it really interesting
[Music]
so I can pretty much control whatever I
need to do
and go from there
but I'm in a spot right now that's like
like really comfortable of what we're
doing
so it's like
we're kind of feeling good
your sources are good just push
so
it's nicer right
oh swords
17.
it's about air
and now we're gonna be back in
it's gonna be great
bar
do you build a business to defend this
is like your town and little by little
you have to
do a man can also
um
you can also do different types of
policies within everything
so it's really really cool how they have
that too so you have
oh
lots of different things you could do
over time it's pretty neat
this way
Source durable
foreign
but I've been playing it for a while so
I like I made it wait wait wait wait
before I learned a lot about it and now
I'm just doing more and more and more
so you kind of just
more the more you play the more you
learn
and it's just I I really do enjoy it
because it's got lots of different
things going on in it
like I'm gonna see if I can take over
this town by becoming friendly with them
I've never done stuff like that before
you take food and you put it in here so
that it restores your dice number
because each of your dices and number
associated to it
and once that goes to zero you lose your
die
so there's all these little things you
learn and then you have technology trees
that you can do different things with
so you have lots of different things you
can do
foreign
military
there is a star
there you got some extra free
Academy
to that first
level four
let's do that
it's crazy I don't think I've ever
gotten this far
they give you a lot of different
[Music]
so we can see both of these dice here
[Music]